Superbass a complete back end for web
and mobile applications based entirely
on free open source software the biggest
challenge when building an app is not
writing code but rather architecting a
complete system that works at scale
products like Firebase and amplify have
addressed this barrier but there's one
big problem they lock you into
proprietary technology on a specific
Cloud platform Superbass was created in
2019 specifically as an open source
Firebase alternative at a high level it
provides two things on the back end we
have infrastructure like a database file
storage and Edge functions that run in
the cloud on the front end we have
client-side sdks that can easily connect
this infrastructure to your favorite
front-end JavaScript framework react
native flutter and many other platforms
as a developer you can manage your
postgres database with an easy to
understand UI which automatically
generates rest and graphql apis to use
in your code the database integrates
directly with user authentication making
it almost trivial to implement row level
security and like fire base it can
listen to data changes in real time
while scaling to virtually any workload
to get started you can self-host with
Docker or sign up for a fully managed
account that starts with a free tier on
the dashboard you can create tables in
your postgres database with a click of a
button insert columns to build out your
schema then add new rows to populate it
with data by default every project has
an authentication schema to manage users
within the application this opens the
door to row level security where you
write policies to control who has access
to your data in addition the database
supports triggers to react to changes in
your data and postgres functions to run
stored procedures directly on the
database server it's a nice interface
but it also automatically generates
custom API documentation for you from
here we can copy queries tailored to our
database and use them in a JavaScript
project install the Super Bass SDK with
npm then connect to your project and
sign a user in with a single line of
code and now we can listen to any
changes to the authentication state in
real time with on off stage change when
it comes to the database we don't need
to write raw SQL code instead we can
paste in that JavaScript code from the
API docs or use the rest and graphql
apis directly and that's all it takes to
build an authenticated full stack
application however you may still want
to run your own custom server-side code
in which case serverless Edge functions
can be developed with Dino and
typescript then easily distributed
around the globe this has been super
bass in 100 seconds if you want to build
something awesome on this platform we
just released a brand new Super Bass
course on fireship i o it's free to get
started so check it out to learn more
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one